I was born in the Ivory Coast in West
Africa
my father bought me and my mom to the
U.S at the tender age of two
when I was five I remember living in
Harlem with my mom and my dad
I came home one day and was told that my
mom no longer loved me and loved us
she left to return back to the Ivory
Coast which left only me and my father
growing up with my dad there was a lot
of
I was in a lot of African cultures was
instilled for instance English is my
second language I spoke French in a
household I
carried out Traditions that my father
was accustomed to when he was growing up
that changed when I was about six years
old I started to assimilate into the
American culture the language and going
into Catholic School
at age six the dreams of
a new life and things that were
different
took a turn
my father started to both emotionally
and physically abuse me
it became so bad I attempted suicide
when I was 13. not this point it was
just me and my dad living in the house
together
I do have a half sister who was born
when I was eight years old but we so we
don't have the same mom
the abuse
caused a lot of
stress it caused me to not want to be
seen I just didn't understand why I was
experiencing such harsh treatment at
home
the emotional abuse looked like being
told that I was stupid dumb like my mom
ugly that I would never amount to
anything these are things that I heard
for 10 years of my life that took a toll
on me
at age 16 my father finally made good on
a promise to take my life and he almost
did
but by the grace of God I was able to
survive
and be able to escape that morning with
my life and put myself in the near
foster care system
the decision to place myself in the New
York foster care system literally saved
my life and for that I will always be
grateful
however there were a lot of obstacles
that I had to overcome
for one I found myself not having any
family being traumatized
then being sexually assaulted by
classmates maybe two weeks into entering
the system and being placed in the home
I had amazing foster parents don't get
me wrong but like I said
I had a lot of trauma that I was dealing
with
dealing with and not dealing with at the
same time I didn't know how to deal with
it for so many years I felt like a
prisoner I felt
I felt unseen unheard I was always
taught you are to be seen not heard your
voice doesn't matter
I never knew how to express myself how
to speak properly how to let people know
what I was feeling or what was going on
with me so I was a bit mute when I was
growing up in foster care
and no one could tell me that anything
was wrong with me I was fine I was fined
you couldn't tell me that there was
anything wrong I made myself believe
that I was okay because I in a way I was
I was out of Harm's Way I was out of
physical
harm
however I still had a lot of emotional
stuff that I had to deal with learning
how to quote unquote be normal I would
always make a joke to my it was like an
inside joke
am I saying the wrong thing am I coming
off weird am I am I scaring people off
of my dream at the time was to be normal
not really knowing what that meant so
and so I've learned
you can run but you can't hide
I stayed in this system from age 16 to
21 at the age of 21 I aged out got my
first Apartments I thought I was hot
stuff I had my first apartments in the
Bronx in The Concourse and
I mean I thought I was like big stuff
here I have friends who are rearranging
their own rooms their rooms with their
parents that they live with and here I
was about to rearrange a whole freaking
apartment
it didn't get any better than that it
was like Party City of course it was
Party City because I was trying to avoid
dealing with whatever emotions and
feelings that I
knew I needed to process but didn't know
how to so there was a period of time
where
my therapist was a bottle of Gray Goose
I found comfort
through drinking and partying and as
much as I love my apartment I never
wanted to be home because I never wanted
to be alone with my thoughts that was
such a terrifying feeling at the time to
sit and actually be present and still
with my thoughts was painful
however it's my belief that God speaks
to us in mysterious ways at the age of
22 about a year after I age out of the
system
I remember having dreams they felt they
felt more like nightmares
they were Vivid
dreams of my mother and I I remember
feeling
rage I hated my mother for leaving
for leaving me with my father and
everything that I had experienced and so
I was holding on to not only did my
father tried to take my life my mother
was gone and I found myself in a system
where the state of New York the city of
New York were my parents it was a lot it
was a lot I felt alone isolated I felt
misunderstood but yet I didn't
understand myself
and so I turned to alcohol at the time
and that led to what felt like at the
time a mental breakdown
I was attending John Jay College at the
time because I wanted to be the Marsha
Clark of foster care I wanted to lock up
people like my dad who her children
and be an advocate for kids who went
through what I went through and at the
time I convinced myself that being an
attorney was the only way to do that and
so I did what I had to do to make that
happen
unfortunately when this mental breakdown
occurred I had to do one of the hardest
things that I had ever done in my life
pause
I had to take a break I had to take a
break and take care of me that was such
a foreign concept to me at the time
because I was always taught to go go
perfectionism you get your degree you do
this like it was just all these
different
programming and beliefs that was
instilled in me that I was working
through
but unfortunately when your body shuts
down you have no choice I I had no
choice but to just pause and be still
and that led me to my very first
therapist
now in our culture my dad taught me that
therapists or the devil you don't speak
to them they are bad news they're after
you and so this was the programming that
was instilled in me so it was it took a
lot for me to just break free from those
limiting beliefs and just trust that I
was going to attract someone that was
going to be able to help me and man I
did the universe is always working in
your favor and will always leave you to
what you're asking for and it did
it led me to this 70 year old ferocious
Jewish lady that was exactly what I
needed at the time she helped me to
process my feelings
she helped she supported me in many
different ways I remember her giving me
like my first
pear pot pot sets when I moved into my
apartment she was very protective and
she felt like home I am forever grateful
for her
after
taking some time off
like I said at the time I was having
these dreams and I felt like God was
speaking to me I would wake up
tears in my eyes not knowing what was
happening and I realized that God was
telling me it was time to find my
biological mother
so I called my aunt
I was like listen I think it's time for
me to find her and get her side of the
story
she agreed and so we decided to hire
someone and look for her and we did
and I remember when she called me and I
picked up the phone
the minute she spoke I already knew it
was my mother like I felt the connection
through the phone before she even said
who she was I felt it
and I remember
not knowing what to say to be honest I
was happy that I found her but at the
same token I was angry
oh man I mean it's like what do you say
hey why did you abandon me you know
that's not how you start a conversation
we spoke we cried
she explained to me what really happened
the day I came home and was told that
she had abandoned me
we lived in Harlem at the time in a
two-bedroom apartment and
my father and her were arguing
she put her hands up to defend herself
and unfortunately she fell out of our
five-story Apartments but by the grace
of God she survived and she took that
opportunity to go back to the Ivory
Coast and in her heart she knew that my
father wouldn't let her take me with her
and she also believed that leaving me
behind here would have been better
because the point of coming here was for
a better life for me
she was horrified to hear that I had
experienced the foster care system and
the things that
occurred during my childhood
so
the paths of forgiveness began
and that was a very hard road because I
had a lot to work through
and I did
slowly but surely
by this time I was working at a very
prestigious Law Firm like I said I had
aspirations of becoming an attorney so I
was looking at the firm I was going
attending John Jay College and my family
in the Ivory Coast
decided that they were going to take
care of my mother they said that
she could stay with them and when I was
ready I could send for her so I was like
great
my mom is in another part of the world
but we can still create a relationship
and I can't change the past but I knew
that I had the power to create something
different moving forward
I'll be honest it was hard it was really
hard to move through
the feelings the hurt the pain but I
decided that I was committed to it and I
was going to do my best you know we had
weekly calls I was trying to figure out
how to get to know her she was getting
to know me we had exchanged pictures I
took a picture of me she took a picture
of her and we made arrangements for it
to reach the other person and we would
sleep with each other's pictures
underneath our pillows at night
and I remember thinking okay you know
it's
I can't change the past but man we're
going to have an amazing future
unfortunately God doesn't care about the
plans that we have
in 2010
my mother
my mother's mother my grandmother
fell sick which triggered my mother's
drinking
my mother used to drink heavily I
remember being four or five years old
living in a one-bedroom apartment in
Brooklyn
and she would be passed out on the couch
I thought she was sleeping but now that
I think back and remember she was
she was passed out drunk
and
my grandmother's sickness triggered her
drinking which led her to do to behave
in ways that was just harmful to my
family and so they told her that she had
to leave
which is understandable
she called me
frantic telling me how they were lying
how you know I couldn't trust them I was
angry I was angry and told her that she
needed to get somewhere safer and that
we would need to figure this out because
I mean I she was staying with my family
who I trusted I knew no one no one else
in the country I I don't know I just
needed to figure things out and so
we spoke that day and unbeknownst to me
I didn't know it would be the last time
I would ever speak to her
after that conversation she went missing
for about a year a year later I remember
spending my 33rd birthday in Paris with
my aunt
and she said well you know you have to
um we have to find your mom and I'm
thinking she brought harm to the family
she had someone come and break down the
door and try to Rob them so she can get
money for alcohol
but what I thought about I was like you
know what my I was right and I need to
find her and I need to figure out how to
move forward as I was processing
now during this time I had experienced
self-development for the first time and
so I was in this space of transitioning
from just being
the angry girl to
someone who's Lively and joyful
self-development came into my life
around that time through the form of a
workshop and I remember just needing
more I was like I need more I need more
this is amazing Letting Go forgiveness
not being the story
and that actually led me to step into
the work that I do now but I'm going to
get back to that
so
I had the tools I had the tools I had
I was in a different mind set in a
different space so
I figured okay you know what let's let's
find my mom
I came back to the States
I started applying for Visa trying to
figure out how to apply for visa for
parents
that summer three months later I get to
receive a phone call and my aunt tells
me that
she found my mother and I was so excited
I was elated I was like okay great yes
oh but she's in a coma I was like okay
that's fine
I believe in God I believe that all
things are possible through God and I
knew that it was going to be okay in my
heart
so
I remember leaving work
I went home
and the next morning of all people my
dad who we were in our really good terms
at this point in my life caused me to
give his condolences and I remember
thinking what is he talking about he was
like well you know I'm sorry my
condolences and I was like what are you
talking about
she was she was like your mom was like
she's in a coma why would you say that
he was like no she's dead literally this
is the words that came out of this man's
mouth she's dead though
and I was like no
and then he hung up on me in the next
minute my aunt in Paris called it was as
if she knew that my dad called or some
cue of some sort to call me in that
moment when I pick up the phone
we were both quiet it was just silence
and I remember I said
dad just called
is it true she said I'm so sorry
and I remember
how heartbroken
I was in that moment
she said be strong
don't cry it's gonna be okay
that's all that I had to hang up and I
wore her back
once I hung up with the phone I remember
just dropping to my knees
and crying like I had never cried before
I cried for all of my parts the
six-year-old
that came home
that came home it was so that her mother
had left
the eight-year-old because when I was
eight my dad did take me to the Ivory
Coast to visit my mom again
but she didn't come back to the states
with us she stayed so it felt like I was
losing her again and I was being
abandoned again I cried for the 16 year
old that experienced foster care and
didn't have her mom around it was like a
deep cry from like the depths of my soul
and then the next minute I remember
everything just happened so fast I
decided that I was going to go back to
the Ivory Coast it had been 20 something
years by that time I had been home since
I had been home
and I was going to say goodbye to my mom
it was important to me even though a lot
of my friends didn't
agree with my decision because there was
supposed harm that would come to me but
I didn't care I know that I was going
with love in my heart and that I needed
to go back to where my story began and
so I did
seven years ago
back to the Ivory Coast to bury my
mother
and I made a promise that her life would
that her death would not go in vain she
was 49 years old
so young so beautiful
and I know that everything happens for a
reason
she's no longer in pain
and so that gives me peace
even though I'm still working through
grief around her death it's been seven
years people say Time Heals all I don't
think so I'm still trying to figure out
how to process but I know that
you just have to make the commitment to
pull one foot forward when you're
dealing with grief
and do your best
I know that she's watching over me we
have conversations every day
I know that she's one of my angels and
supporters
and so that brings me peace
it also brought Clarity to me with
everything that has happened I was like
you know what
being an attorney I don't think that's
it I want to step into my purpose and so
here's the thing
things are going to happen in life some
messed up things are going to happen
some messed up things happen to me and I
am grateful for those experiences
these experiences supported me in
stepping into my purpose and being the
person that I am today as a coach as a
writer as a speaker I wouldn't be doing
the work today that I do with women and
my advocacy work within the foster care
system had I not gone through what I
went through and I know it sounds like
well man did you have to go through that
to get here yes
we are it is my
it is my belief that we are souls having
this Human Experience and we chose we
chose this life we're here we're here to
create impact we are here to share our
gifts our stories and to inspire others
so people know that no matter what
you've been through
it is going to be okay and the Sun Will
Come Out Tomorrow
and so I'm just grateful In This Moment
I'm grateful for everything that has
happened for me not to me because it has
led me up to this very moment
thank you so much fam
beautiful story